- [Instructor] What we're
going to do in this video
is think about how shapes' properties
might be preserved or not
preserved from dilations
and so here we have this quadrilateral
and we're going to dilate
it about point P here
and I have this little Dilation tool.
So the first question is
are the coordinates of the
vertices going to be preserved?
Well, pause the video and
try to think about that.
Let's just try it out experimentally.
We can see under an
arbitrary dilation here,
the coordinates are not preserved.
The point that corresponds to D
now has a different coordinate.
The vertices, the vertex
that corresponds to A
now has different coordinates.
Same thing for B and C.
The corresponding points
after the dilation
now sit on a different part
of the coordinate plane.
So in this case, the
coordinates of the vertices
are not preserved.
Now, the next question, let
me go back to where we were.
So the next question,
the corresponding line
segments after dilation,
are they sitting on the same line
and so let me dilate again
and so you can see if you
consider this point B prime
'cause it corresponds to point B,
the segment B prime C prime,
this does not sit on the same line as BC
but the segment D prime,
the corresponding line
segment to line segment AD,
that does sit on the same line
and if you think about why that is,
well, if we originally draw a line that,
if we look at the line
that contains segment AD,
it also goes through point
P and so as we expand out,
this segment right over here
is going to expand and shift
outward along the same lines
but that's not going to be
true of these other segments
because they don't,
because the point P
does not sit on the line
that those segments sit on
and so let's just expand it again
so you see that right over there.
Now, the next question, are
angle measures preserved?
Well, it looks like they are
and this is one of the things
that is true about a dilation
is that you're going to
preserve angle measures.
This angle is still a right angle.
This angle here, I guess
you can call it angle,
the measure of angle B
is the same as the
measure of angle B prime
and you can see it with all of
these points right over there
and then the last question.
Are side lengths, perimeter
and area preserved?
Well, we can immediately
see as we dilate outwards,
for example, the segment
corresponding to AD
has gotten longer.
In fact, if we dilate
outwards, all of the segments,
the corresponding segments
are getting larger
and if they're all getting larger
then the perimeter's getting larger
and the area's getting larger.
Likewise, if we dilate in like this,
they're all getting smaller.
So side lengths, perimeter
and area are not preserved.
Now, let's ask the same
questions with another dilation
and this is going to be interesting
because we're going to look at a dilation
that is centered at one of
the vertices of our shape.
So let me scroll down here
and so I have the same tool again
and now here we have a
triangle, triangle ABC
and we're gonna dilate about point C.
So first of all, do we think the vertices,
the coordinates of the vertices
are going to be preserved?
Let's dilate out.
Well, you can see point C is preserved.
When it gets mapped after the dilation,
it sits in the exact same place
but the things that correspond
to A and B are not preserved.
You could call this A prime
and this definitely has
different coordinates than A
and B prime definitely has
different coordinates than B.
Now, what about
corresponding line segments?
Are they on the same line?
Well, some of them are
and some of them aren't.
So for example, when we dilate,
so let's look at the segment
AC and the segment BC,
when we dilate, we can see, whoops,
when we dilate, we can see
the corresponding segments,
you could call this A prime
C prime or B prime C prime,
do still sit on that same line
and that's because the point
that we are dilating about,
point C, sat on those original segments.
So we're essentially just lengthening out
on the point that is not
the center of dilation.
We're lengthening out away from it
or if the dilation is going in,
we would be shortening
along that same line
but some of the segments
are not overlapping on the same line.
So for example, A prime B prime
does not sit along the same line as AB.
Now, what about the angle measures?
Well, we already talked about it.
Angle measures are
preserved under dilations.
The measure of angle C here,
this is the exact same angle
and so is the measure of angle
you could call this A prime
and B prime right over here.
And then finally, what about side lengths?
Well, you can clearly see
that when I dilate out,
my side lengths increase
or if I dilate in,
my side lengths decrease
and so side lengths are not preserved
and if side lengths are not preserved
then the perimeter is not preserved
and also the area is not preserved.
You could view area as a
function of the side lengths.
As we dilate out like this,
the perimeter grows and so does the area.
If we dilate in like this,
the perimeter shrinks
and so does the area.